fill in the blanks to form a system of
linear equations in the variables x and
y with infinitely many solutions so
you're going to have infinitely many
solutions if essentially both of these
equations are describing the same line
if they're both essentially the same
equation they are the same constraint
and we can graphically imagine that
let's say that that's our y-axis and
this is our
x-axis and we could even try to graph
this right over here if we were to put
this into slope intercept form you would
have five y is equal to two minus four x
and then if we divide both sides by five
you get y is equal to and i'll swap
these negative four fifths x
plus
two
so this line up here this line up here
is going to look something like this
it's y-intercept is it two-fifths
it's a two-fifths and it's going to have
a negative four-fifth slope so it's
going to look something like this
it's gonna look something
something
like that so that's what the line looks
like so we're going to get an infinite
number of solutions for the system if
the second line if when we graph it is
essentially the exact same line it
overlaps at every x and y that satisfy
the first equation now the easiest way
to think about what these blanks should
be is well how can i manipulate this so
it is essentially or how do i fill in
the blanks here so it is really just a
direct algebraic manipulation of this
first equation and we have a clue here
on the right hand side of the first
equation we have a 2 on the right hand
side of the second equation we have a 4.
so if we want to direct algebraic
manipulation clearly on the right hand
side you have multiplied by 2 and if you
want this to be the same equation you
have to do that to both sides so let's
multiply both sides
by 2. so 4x times 2 is 8x
5y times 2 is 10 y so this equation and
this equation are the exact same
constraint they represent the exact same
line they have an infinite number of
solutions let's do another example
which of the following choices of a of a
will result in a system of linear
equations with no solutions
so you're going to have no solutions is
if you take the same combination of x
and y's but you get to a different
number or another way of thinking about
it is if you plotted this equation it
had the exact same slope but it had a
different y-intercept so let's do it
let's think about it both ways so first
i'll think about it let's try to let's
try to algebraically manipulate the
second equation
so that the left hand side looks exactly
the same as the left hand side up here
and then we just have to make sure that
the right hand side is different and
then you will have no solutions so let's
let's think about that a little bit so
it looks pretty close if we multiply the
left hand side by a negative one it's
going to look just like the left hand
side over here so let's do that let's
multiply the left hand and the right
hand side by negative one so it's
essentially the same equation so
negative six x times negative 1 is
positive 6x
7y times negative 1 is minus 7y
and a times negative 1 is negative a
so notice now on the left hand side we
have the same combinations of x's and
y's we have x's minus seven y's we have
six x's minus seven y's
if on the right hand side if on the
right hand side these two things were to
be equal then we'd have the scenario
that we just saw we would have the exact
same line if negative a was equal to 4
we would have the same lines let me
write that down if negative a is equal
to 4 then we're dealing with the same
same line
slash equation slash
constraint and like the previous
scenario we would have an infinite
number of solutions
infinite
infinite solutions
on the other hand if negative a is not
equal is not equal to four then there's
no way that there's anything that will
satisfy both of them here you're saying
whatever your x is whatever your y's
take six of the x's subtract seven of
the y's you get four if here you take
six of the x's and subtract seven of the
y's and you get a different number then
there's never going to be an x and a y
that satisfy both of them
so if negative a is not equal to 4 then
you're going to have no
no solutions or another way of saying
this is if a does not equal negative 4
obviously if a is equal to negative 4
then negative a is going to be equal to
4. so as long as a is not equal to
negative 4 you're going to have no
no
solutions so a can be any number except
for
except for
negative 4. now another way to think
about this is to visual put what they're
both in slope intercept form and and
you'll see that they'll have the same
slope and then you just want to have
them have different y-intercepts and
they're going to be parallel lines that
don't overlap
so this top one right over here
this top one right over here if we
subtract 6x from both sides you get
negative 7y is equal to negative 6x
plus 4
divide both sides by negative 7 you get
y is equal to 6 7 x
minus 4 7. so that's this first one
right up here written in slope intercept
form now the second one i'll just start
with exactly what they gave us let me
add 6x to both sides so this is the
second one so if i add 6x to both sides
i get 7y
is equal to
6x plus
a and then if i divide both sides by 7 i
get y is equal to 6 over 7 x
plus a
over 7. so notice
notice in slope-intercept form our first
equation looks like that and in terms of
a our second equation looks like that
so they definitely already they
definitely already have the same slope
they have the exact same slope if a is
equal to
if a is equal to negative 4 then these
are going to be the exact same equations
they're going to have the exact same
y-intercept you're going to have an
infinite number of solutions on the
other hand if a is anything other than
negative 4 you're going to have a
different y-intercept and these two
things are just going to be parallel